The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: Let me
go through the second set
of papers with you, which
deal with today's class.
On the first page, is a
diagram, two diagrams of Paris.
If London-- what are the
major features of London
that we discussed on Tuesday?
The rights of citizens to
control their own land.
Because they [INAUDIBLE]
through the reign of Charles II.
Secondly, the decision
to make transportation,
public transportation,
a fundamental aspect
of the organization of
the city leading to,
amongst others,
to lower density.
Thirdly, the presence
of the aristocracy
in the center of the
city, subdividing to take
care of a rising
middle-income middle class.
The rest are details.
The fire and the
plague, just disasters
which brought about
certain fundamental changes
such as the imposition
of the new sewage system.
Paris is a very different city.
You've all been to Paris, so
you know what I'm talking about,
I hope.
For reasons which are not clear
to me, in the 18th century
already, in 1750,
there was a competition
held by Louis XV, who was
already safely ensconced
in Versailles, 18 miles
from the center of Paris.
This is not a place to eat.
I'm sorry, Michaela.
It's difficult to have
classes at lunchtime, but--
STUDENT: Sorry.
JULIAN BEINART: It's OK.
Is it cold or hot?
STUDENT: Cold.
JULIAN BEINART:
Oh, so it'll last.
There was a competition to make
the center of Paris resemble
Versailles.
It was won by a man
called Patte, P-A-T-T-E.
And I will show the plan.
The elements of
the plan establish
a number of fundamentals.
First of all, there are walls.
Look at the number of walls
that encompass the city
from over the 900 years--
well, even more than the
900 years as a kingdom.
The first wall, in 1250--
the first wall in AD 250.
That was a Roman wall.
The Romans left,
more or less, 500 AD.
The subsequent walls are
the 12th century wall,
the 14th century wall,
the 17th century wall,
the 18th century wall, the 19th
century wall, the Périphérique.
You'll notice that
whenever an enclosing wall
hits a main axis--
in this case, the
Champs-Élysées--
there's an important place.
The Étoile, the Porte Maillot,
the Place de la Concorde.
Paris has-- was built out of
three fundamentals, streets,
walls, and--
there were three.
One is escaping for the moment.
Let's just continue
through this.
The next page is the final
step in the transformation
of the center of Paris
by the work of Haussmann,
from about 1850 to 1872.
1872 marks the end of
the kingdoms of Paris,
which started with in 987 AD.
And the third of the components
that I was going to mention
were monuments.
Prime example of
a monument which
persists from the beginning
in the 12th century, added to
and transformed over time by
kings and their queens giving
it its final shape through the
work of Louis Napoleon III.
And then, finally, the Arc
du Carrousel, the center
point being the work of
an American architect.
The diagram below is
from work and writing
by Guy Debord, which argues--
Guy Debord and Asger
Jorn and Victor Constant,
all participants in the movement
called the Situationists.
Situationists believed
in something they
called psychogeography.
That was the system in which
the experience of cities which
was not delimitated
by simple boundaries.
This diagram indicates that
the experience of Paris
is much to be made, not through
the compartments designed,
administrative
components designed
by Haussmann, but as a
free system of movement,
much like a taxi ride
moves through a city,
independent of boundaries.
There is a film
which they referred
to which I can't remember.
It's a film of a
French prostitute
who works freely in the city.
I tried.
I can't remember.
The next page indicates
another use of the streets.
1848-- the two revolutions
of 1848 and 1871,
the idea of the street as
a system of barricades.
The next page is a section
through the boulevard house.
This is a typical section in a
Haussmann elevation, one, two,
three, four, five, floors, the
fifth floor being the roof.
There's a pharmacy
on the ground floor,
some commercial activity.
The first and second
and third floors
are middle-class apartments,
and the top floor
is where the artists
[INAUDIBLE] La Boheme
and La Traviata and so on
happened in the top floor.
This construction is one of the
keys to the density of Paris.
Paris has always been dense.
It's attracted enormous
amount-- it was the greatest
manufacturing city in the
second half of the 19th century
and attracted immigrants.
Not national, not
extranational immigrants,
but rural immigrants to the
city between the period of 18--
oh.
We'll get there.
OK, I think that's
the last of the pages.
The walls are interesting
for a number of reasons.
They consume capital.
The last 19th century wall
created a large space north
of the current Haussmann city.
Today, two million people
live in the center of Paris
and six million people live
in the Banlieues, which is
the suburban sprawl condition.
Which the competition,
Sarkozy's competition of 19--
what are we?
Or 2008, which some
example-- and we'll
go through some examples
from that competition.
So, essentially, the other
interesting aspect of the wall
was that it paid.
It brought in a lot of money
to Haussmann's capacity
to engage in loans from banks
to pay for the purchase of land
in order to divide--
[INAUDIBLE] his
new road systems.
The octroi, O-C-T-R-O-I, was
a major source of income.
Wine and food was
taxed at the gate.
This is a device
which is still common.
Robert Moses used the
income because he controlled
the taxation system of
transportation into New York
through the bridges and tunnels.
In Boston, we have
the same silliness,
that we still pay tolls
to the authority which
runs the Seaport,
badly, and the airport.
It's an old system,
paying at the gate.
So we want to look at
900 years of history,
and I'm just going to pick
out some aspects of it
because, really, one--
this is an enormous topic.
And I want to concentrate on
the spatial environmental issues
and relate them
back historically.
So, for instance, Henry
IV, one of the great kings
of Paris, 1533 to
1610, had a second wife
called Marie de' Medici.
There were two
Medici women who were
important in these
years in Paris.
She introduced another idea
into the street system.
In Florence, streets
were closed so
that people could play games.
The games were called, in
Italian, magliare, to hit,
la palla, a ball.
Right?
STUDENT: Magliare?
JULIAN BEINART: Magliare.
Maglio is a hammer, isn't it?
STUDENT: Yeah.
Never heard, that one.
But, yeah, maglio is a hammer.
Yes.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah,
magliare la palla
is the phrase which
is used to describe
the games they played like
croquet, with hitting a ball.
There are versions of
this game, obviously.
The area around
Buckingham Palace,
where Regent Street's going
through Piccadilly Circus,
runs into the Crown
near [INAUDIBLE] area,
is called Pall Mall.
The place where American
teenagers meet is a mall.
Magliare la palla,
Pall Mall, mall.
The Cours la Reine in Paris
became as Marie de' Medici
built it, who was responsible
for its construction,
became a place where French
could meet in their carriages
and have flirtations with other
members of either the same sex
or the opposite sex.
Essentially, it was a--
it took an idea of a street
as an environment for play
and transformed it into another
version of the same idea.
So the streets of Paris
played almost every role
you can imagine.
This is, linguistically,
an interesting reach,
from closing a
street in Florence
to play a game to use the
same word etymologically,
now being used for--
to describe an American
shopping center.
Any connection?
I don't know.
Nor I've seen this explained.
Perhaps the mall
became a general term,
and the Americans picked it up
and applied it indiscriminantly
of its origin.
Absolutely.
Well, the Romans crossed the
river, as they did in London,
but found an island
about 20 acres large
in the center of the river
which became the foundation
of the city of Paris.
The Romans stayed until
about the fifth century.
One of the governors
of the Romans was--
had my name.
He was a cousin--
he was a nephew of the
Emperor Constantine.
He then became the last
of the Roman emperors.
He was killed by his
own troops because he
was unlike his uncle
or a Christian.
He believed in stemming
the Christian epidemic
and wanted Rome to remain in
touch with the Mithrian rights
and multigods and systems
of religion, which was being
sabotaged by Christianity.
I'm just going to
go through some
of the aspects of this spatial
system is put into place.
Philippe August, 1180 to 1223,
built on the Ile de Cité,
the island.
He built a palace, the
beginning of the Louvre,
the law courts, the bishop's
palace, Ile de Cite,
all on the 20 acres.
He built the second wall.
He already agitated for the
rebuilding of Les Halles.
Les Halles, the
land of Les Halles
was developed and
occupied by Jews.
In the 12th century,
it was common to be--
for kings to be anti-Semitic.
The Jews were expelled
from their property,
and Les Halles was built.
So when you go to Les Halles
today, which are now an
underground shopping center,
you'll have to think back to
understand that it was land
from which Jews were expelled.
In England, at the
same time, Jews
had to wear a badge
to show themselves as
different from ordinary people.
They had to pay tax when
they entered or left London.
And Henry II, I think it was.
So the behavior
of the French King
was in sync, synchronized with
the behavior of his colleagues
out in Europe.
Notre Dame was built
in the 12th century.
So centered is Paris in
the geography of France
that, even today, all
measurements in France
measured from Notre Dame.
There isn't that sense of
centrality in the London.
There were crowds gathered
to watch a hanging,
but nothing like
the crowds which
gathered to watch the guillotine
and to watch people be headed,
to wath cats being fried.
The great King Henry
IV, a 16th century king
whose second wife
Marie de' Medici
I've mentioned already in
relation to Cours la Reine,
he built a large section of the
central part of Paris, bridges,
palaces, churches, gardens.
He built the Pont Neuf.
He also built the
Place Royale, which
is the largest residential
square in Europe
and the predictor of
the Covent Garden model.
The Cours la Reine, at
least the Place Royale,
which is now the
Place des Vosges,
is 140 meters, if I
remember correctly,
140 meters by 140 meters.
It's the largest residential
public space in Europe,
built as the residence for the
royalty and the aristocracy.
A number of attributes of the
street system were reinforced--
oh, let me just--
just want the correct quotation.
"On April the 10th, 1783,
the first royal declaration
of an urban policy
was promulgated.
It was worth noting that it
followed an accurate map."
Turgot, he made the first
correct map of Paris.
It was correct in the sense
that it was more accurate
than the typical perspective
view of cities up to that time.
The Great Map of Rome
by Nolli was 1748.
And Turgot did as best he could.
The great first
orthographic map of Paris
was the work of a Burgundian
architect called Verniquet.
Verniquet took
accurate measurements
during the day in the
crowded Paris streets.
His grand observations were
corrected by triangulation
to determine the
elevations of the city.
In 1783, there's an
interesting connection
between the availability of an
accurate map and the capacity
to make a pronouncement
of urban policy.
The streets are important
for the public welfare.
They ought to be sufficiently
wide and free of any barriers
to the free and easy passage
of vehicles and pedestrians.
They further asserted
that overly tall buildings
were prejudicial to clean air
in a city as populous as Paris
as well as contrary to public
safety and prone to fire.
Already, in 1793,
there was not only
the ability to demarcate
space accurately
because of an accurate
map, but the capacity
to put into place
regulations which
decided what the
dimensions of a street
were and also of the
ruling, which has lasted
in central Paris
ever since, and that
is not to allow tall buildings.
Whilst the spatial
idea of having
as direct a distance between
two monumental points
was an idea which
had been around
in French landscape
for a long time,
there was nobody, really,
who could articulate
that idea in practice.
The street system was
not only for play.
It was for rapid movement.
Denied by the building
of barricades,
the street system
was also a sequence
of connectivity between
various aspects of the city.
Already, early on,
the French King
decided that the university
would be on the Left Bank
and commerce would
be on the Right Bank.
But instead of developing
these as the sole elements
of the space, a system of
avenues which connected
the important points, often
monuments, reticulated and made
a multidimensional space,
in this case, a box
base of limited height but
a compressed space, now
of two million people, all
articulated by the rulings
about streets.
Haussmann, who became
prefect in 1851,
was really responsible for
being the first urban manager
in any city in
relatively recent times.
What he did was
take an idea which
was in the DNA of the French
Parisian system of streets
and make it possible.
Paris was an unruly
medieval city.
It was-- you read
Stendhal, he talks
about the mud in the streets
and the filth in the streets.
It was no different from
most cities at that time.
And it also was the
site of cholera.
There were great cholera
epidemics in 1839 and in 1842.
There were workers
riots regularly
in 1830s, the 1840s,
this following
that Great Revolution of 1789.
Haussmann arrived
after the failure
of the last-- second-last
king to maintain his position,
and he was replaced
by Louis Napoleon.
Louis Napoleon
had been in exile.
And there are stories of
him being in Durgin-Park,
in the restaurant
in Boston, talking
about this great new city
that he was going to build
when he went back to Paris.
He had watched Regent
Street in London
and, with great
admiration for the--
what built Regent
Street in London.
The compact included
permission by the Parliament,
a million pounds of
money from the bank,
and the right to
purchase property
in order that the property
may be transformed according
to a street system.
Louis Napoleon was
obsessed with this idea
that he could rebuild Paris.
He happens to be the last
king in the history of Paris.
He made a bad decision to
start a war with the Prussians,
and Paris was bombarded and
the court moved to Versailles
and a republic was
established after the war.
So Haussmann's 20
years are 20 years
at the end of 900 years
of royal regime in Paris.
You cannot account for a similar
set of circumstances in London
or in Vienna or in Berlin or any
of the great European cities.
Haussmann was a maniac
for a number of things.
Spatially, I don't know
about his personal life here.
That's another story altogether.
He wanted absolute control.
He says to the Emperor--
when they have the first meeting
of the town planning commission
and there are lots of
speeches and everybody's
sitting around--
he talks to the Emperor
after the meeting
and says, "What a waste of time.
All these people like big
speeches, and nothing happened.
We don't get any work done."
The Emperor says, "Well,
how big does the commission
have to be?"
He says, "Well, the Emperor,
you would have to be there
and I have to be there, and I
can't think of anybody else."
The Emperor says, "Sounds
like a good plan to me."
So the commission becomes one
man, the Prefect of the Seine.
Rambuteau, the Prefect
of the Seine before him--
there were a number of others,
Berger and Persigny and so on--
but Rambuteau tried to
extend the East-West access
to the Bastille, as Napoleon
tried to do, but failed.
He proposed the street which
has his name, the Rue Rambuteau,
but could only afford
to build it out
of the budget of the city.
He could build one mile, and
he was allowed to make it.
He only asked for
13 meters width.
He was allowed 20 meters.
But the story of Rambuteau is
the story of the fact that you
cannot do a major reconstruction
of a city out of the capital
budget of the city.
What the greatest
invention of Haussmann,
it was not easy arrangement,
but economists like Saint-Simon
constructed the idea that if you
improved an asset, its worth,
no matter how much you
invest in the improvement,
its worth in the end is going
to pay it back many times.
It's called deficit
spending, today.
And Haussmann
understood that in order
to rebuild Paris from being a
medieval slum to a modern city,
you needed to
develop more capital
than the ordinary taxation
system in the city can do.
So he took the money from the
octroi system, borrowed money.
He expropriated land.
In 1783-- no.
Slowly, in the 18th century, the
control of Paris by the kings
diminished.
And when the rule-- after
the Revolution, of course,
there were no kings until Louis
Philippe and Louis Napoleon.
The notion that you could move
people out of their domains,
rebuild the premises in
which they lived, and not
care for them through
replacement accommodation
and so on, took hold
under Haussmann.
Haussmann, in 20
years, rebuilt Paris
in ways which were part of
the DNA street system of Paris
and made possible, in modern
times, by deficit spending.
The loans which
Haussmann accumulated
in the 20 years where
only repaid in 1929,
but Paris was an immensely
more valuable city in 1929
than it was in 1850.
So we have the introduction into
the urban system of a business
model, of a management model.
Haussmann had his
own predilections.
He did not believe that
individual buildings
were important.
He believed that the systems
of building were important.
He hated the idiosyncrasy.
All the buildings had
to be the same height.
There's an image
in what I gave you.
There's a photograph
of a street in Paris
where he forces the
property on the left
to shift its turret
to the street in order
that it balance a building
on the opposite side
of the street.
What else?
This is an enormously
long story,
but I'm giving you
the bounds of it.
If you're interested,
there's good literature
on the history of
Paris and certainly
the period of 1850 to 1870.
What else can I say before
we look at some images?
This is about as bare
a description of Paris
as I can imagine.
But the extraordinary
capacity for the street system
to be the major articulator
of movement, of war,
of play, of distribution,
of psychogeography,
Haussmann felt that if
you look down an avenue,
you had to have a closed vista.
You had to be led to something
which was an important place.
In Washington, which has a
kind of Parisian kind of plan,
the intersections of
the diagonal avenues,
where they meet each
other, produce nothing.
In Paris, there's always an
important square or monument.
When Haussmann decides that we--
that the city needs an opera,
he builds the Rue de Opera
and then the opera itself.
The opera, it has an
extraordinary interior.
Adding to the complexity of the
spatial relationship of access
to the opera--
the facade of the opera is
a monument standing freely
in space--
and then the entrance and
interior, a fantastic interior,
as well.
What you have in this
Haussmannian system
is this state set of
multifunctional connectors
tying decentralized
aspects of it.
There's no center to Paris.
There are many centers.
You have, as you'll see
in some of the slides,
passages connecting
with covered roofs
in between the boulevards.
You have an articulate and
very elementary system based,
as I say, on of DNA of Paris
since the 15th century.
Why the French
articulated their space
around the idea of minimizing
distance between points
and being articulate about that
distance and the experience
of that distance is
still, to me, unclear.
But it's absolutely different
from the case of London,
where we have one
street, Regent Street,
artifacted in a similar pathway.
As Haussmann did it,
the scale of a city.
I need to see if there's
anything else I should say.
Any questions?
STUDENT: If I understood
what you said earlier,
it was that the idea of a street
or a path connecting monuments
is like an older
idea than Haussmann.
If I understood you
correctly, like, where
did that originate from, like
in Paris or in French culture?
JULIAN BEINART:
Well, I don't know.
As you'll see, in
the second slide I
will show you of an image of
streets in the 15th century--
oh, it's later.
It's probably 17th
century Paris.
You will see
diagonal road systems
in these rural
areas around Paris
as well as in some
in Paris itself.
When I talk about
the DNA of a city,
I don't know exactly
what I'm saying.
It's a biological
explanation, assuming
that there are repetitive
elements, significant elements
in a culture, which repeat.
Often, we don't quite know why.
I often think that the
French are probably
more direct than anybody
else philosophically
and probably decided,
like Bismarck did,
that the way to fight a war
is to go in a straight line
because you'll find nobody
else on the straight line.
Everybody else is fussing
around all over the place.
It's the direct
avenue to accomplish
the friction of distance.
I can't-- I wish
I could answer it.
I'm sure a French, if we
had a French scholar here
or a French historian,
there may be a--
I've often looked for an
answer, but I haven't found it.
It's interesting to
raise that question
because, now, two
million people are living
in this precious construction,
and six million people are
living in bungalows, in public
housing, because public housing
was not asserted as an
element to be incorporated
into the Haussmannian puzzle.
The city now has
this empty sprawl,
which everybody dislikes.
And Sarkozy says, I need
to do something about it.
I don't know if you
followed this competition.
Did you?
Did you see the results?
STUDENT: I remember seeing
some of these renderings,
but I don't know.
I don't know what's going to--
JULIAN BEINART:
Oh, it was, I'm--
I don't know if there's a book
of the entrants now available,
but it was subject to a lot
of publicity at the time.
And the images I've
just gathered here
are taken from some of
the publicity at the time.
A number of things that one
wants to say about this.
Everybody acknowledges
that the way to enlarge--
not to enlarge,
to fill the space,
empty space around
the concentrated city,
is not to expand
the city itself.
None of the 10 entries
in the competition which
use streets, avenues,
diagonalized systems
as an extension of
the Haussmannian grid.
There are many attempts to
do strong constructions,
strong constructions
meaning constructions
which have a strong
physical spatial dimension.
For instance, Grumbach proposes
that Paris will extend itself
westward along with the Seine
to accommodate something
like 16 million people,
arguing that every great city
in the world is a
port city and Paris
should become a port city.
A linear city of 16 miles--
or 16 million people would take
about an hour by public transit
or fast train from
Paris to Rouen.
And it's a strong idea.
You can imagine a city
like this, following
this pattern and developing
interesting relationships
between public transportation
along the water
and many aspects of it.
What will stop it
from developing
the same condition of sprawl
as now exists, I don't know.
He doesn't detail very
much about anything other
than the concept itself.
There are some
crazy propositions.
The one is to take, just
close the Gare du Nord
and shift the Gare do
Nord into the Banlieues
and have it as the premier
railway station in Europe.
Richard Rogers, the
British architect,
has a modest proposal.
He's really interested
in the the politics
of all of the groups
in the Banlieues
and how they could
be brought together.
He extends some of
the radial system,
but covers them with green--
remember that the
computation was called
for post-Kyoto Resolution.
Post-Kyoto means that the
ecological consequences
of the plan were important.
Jean Nouvel, for instance--
many of the competitors proposed
to cover all the buildings
with sun collectors, energy
collectors from the sun.
Jean Nouvel says,
all of the housing,
public housing built
in the Banlieues
are just bad buildings.
They just can't keep
them and convert them
in as interesting and
dramatic and up-to-date
fashion as possible.
He says silly
things like, "Paris
must become the great art
center of the world again."
He proposes something on
the Ile de Cité which I
can't understand.
There's almost a sense of
tiredness about the scheme,
as if there isn't
really a formula
anymore for making urban space.
Haussmann has really
terminated 900 years
of French royal effort to build
walls, to build monuments.
Imagine having a monument in
the center of a city which
was built by the first king
and then torn down and rebuilt
by the second king and
then rebuilt and rebuilt
and rebuilt and
rebuilt as the Paris--
as a palace, ending
up with I.M. Pei doing
a kind of central focal
point for it after it
becomes a museum after a
thousand years of palace.
It's the largest
museum in the world,
I think, and certainly
probably the most significant.
Yet it's on the River Seine.
It blocks access to the river.
It's a big block of
something or other.
It's as permanent as
the city, and there's
no moving it as many have.
And there's, in
a class later on,
we look at temporary
environments in cities.
I will go through the various
French five French exhibitions
in the center of Paris.
1855, four years after the
Crystal Palace; 1868; 1879,
I think; 1889; and 1900.
1889, of course,
the Eiffel Tower.
Jean Giraudoux, the
French playwright,
talks about the center of
Paris as being a stone site,
a permanent, fixed,
[INAUDIBLE] set of operations,
and these temporary
exhibitions are the sort
of way of animating them.
It's like a circus coming
to small town once a year.
It's an extraordinary
idea, that a city
could be fossilized in
some sort of way, gaining
in prestige, becoming
the greatest tourist
city of the world.
Why is Paris the greatest
tourist city of the world?
What is there about
its spatial strategy
that I've tried to spend
an hour talking about that
makes it so attractive?
Is it everybody's last
opportunity somehow?
It's the last
construction of cities
that made sense to people,
that you knew where you were,
that it had an enormous
degree of relatability,
much like Manhattan.
Manhattan's plan is
as naive, perhaps,
as linking a bunch of
nodal points with streets.
Any thought about that?
Finn Geipel's plan
in the computation
is an MIT kind of plan.
He was, three years,
a visiting professor
before the competition.
It's a kind of eco-friendly
city with no particular form,
high degrees of--
there's low visibility, but
high degrees of communication
through telephones,
through all kinds
of modern electronic
conveniences.
What am I saying?
Am I arguing that we have
lost a formula for doing
things which have impact?
All we do is build taller
buildings with funnier shapes.
STUDENT: This doesn't
answer your question,
but it's something that
I'm needing to go back to.
When Haussmann, and you were
talking about that being
in the DNA of Paris, the idea,
on things I've always thought
about Haussmann that never seems
to get talked about as much is
the relationship of those
streets to the medieval streets
and how it's--
I mean that's like the
big difference or one
of the differences
between how the city works
and how Haussmann's
intervention in Cairos works
is Haussmann's streets work in
a context of the preexisting
streets, versus just
laying those down
and that being your whole
strategy for having a city.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
You'll see, on some of
the slides, some plans
of the Haussmann roads impacting
the existing medieval texture.
It's pretty ruthless.
I mean, you know, there's no--
STUDENT: But the--
JULIAN BEINART:
--notion that the people
who live under the system,
there's no replacement.
They pay a marginal penalty
for acquiring the land,
but there's no--
urban renewal, in this country,
produced no great evocative
features either.
My point-- it's
rather a nasty point--
is that if you're
going to be brutal,
at least produce
something worthwhile.
[LAUGHTER]
If you're going to be
nasty, do it to some effect.
It's a horrible
principle in modern life
where we are inclined
to not give power.
I mean, Haussmann
construed the rules
so that it was possible
for the Prefect
of the Seine, the chief
management officer of the city,
to decide which property
could be confiscated.
There was no such ruling ever
in England, and certainly not
in the United States,
under urban renewal.
But I'm trying to make
the argument that we
are in a different time.
We have different
commodities to work with.
But there's a sense that--
I know.
I mean, the critique of
Haussmann's plan by architects
has been fairly general and
quite right in many respects.
Richard [INAUDIBLE] argument
against the subdivision
of the Arondissement
by Haussmann
in the political units and the
Banlieues being left alone,
yeah.
I mean, perhaps I'm talking
about a lost nostalgia
for a lost unity which
we've now dispatched
in favor of a greater sense of
well-being about all people.
I don't know if you saw a movie
called La Haine, The Hate,
by an American director,
I think Arthur Moskovitz.
STUDENT: Mathieu Kassovitz.
JULIAN BEINART:
Mathieu Kassovitz.
Do you remember the movie?
STUDENT: Yeah, I'm a fan.
JULIAN BEINART: It's
an extraordinary movie.
It follows a group of young
men from the Banlieues,
where they are surrounded
by sculpture in public place
in this rather dismal new town.
They venture into Paris, into
the heart of the Old City,
and start destroying
environments.
They go into cocktail parties
and drink all the wine.
They become just an
intolerable nuisance.
And one of them is killed.
I don't remember
how he dies, but--
do you remember?
STUDENT: That's the very end.
He gets shot by a cop,
but that's actually back
in the Banlieues.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
For those of you who know
Henri Lefebvre's work,
the right to the town
is exemplified by that.
If you have two distinct
towns, if you grow up
on the wrong side
of the railroad,
you are disestablished in
your right to the town.
In Paris, which becomes more and
more expensive, more and more,
the great tourist center
of the world building
more and more museums, artifacts
along the quay of the river,
the curious quays of the
river, the competition
is not going to work.
The competition for
cities is a waste of time.
The variables are too
mentally complicated, too.
City planning is not a unique--
a one sort of a time exercise.
The only plan I
know of a city that
was any good as a competition,
although it was never built,
was the Green City competition
in Russia, La Ville Verte.
Which we'll-- when
we deal with Russia,
we will spend some time talking,
looking at that competition.
But competitions are
poor models for working
through some of the
issues we've talked about.
No wonder none of these
plans ever get to pass.
Sarkozy's not
president any longer.
I don't know what's going
to happen, if anything.
Let's look at some
of these images
because they tell more of
the story than my words.
I hope somebody--
none of French history
because I've been very
irresponsible in plundering
French history.
Here's the Roman crossing and
the Ile de la Cité and some
images of the Bishop's palace.
This is prior to Notre
Dame, the law courts
centering in the 20 acres,
in the center, almost
all the components
of the earlier city.
Next.
Here are the diagrams
that interest me.
This is a 1750 plan of
Paris and its surroundings.
What are these things?
These are hunting grounds.
These, somebody once said
to me that these are,
if you designed a
hunting environment,
you would diagonalize
the road and have
many points of contact.
This is Patte's--
Louis XIV, having emancipated
himself from Paris,
many of these kings, yeah, were
alienated from their home city
and left.
Peter, the great tsar
of Russia did as well.
Here, you can see a plan
which has as its principle
a set of points,
diagonals spreading,
connecting to other points.
The beginnings of a plan which
suggest my argument of a DNA.
Le Corbusier's
Voisin plan for Paris
has none of that spirit at all.
It's a ruthless
repositioning of modernism
as against the
canonical street system.
Next.
Well, these are
just fairly obvious.
It's interesting to
contrast the plan of London.
It's about the same scale
as the plan of Paris.
Paris circumvented by walls,
one stretching further out
than the other.
London and being a free set of
connected, loosely connected,
villages, all encompassed
much more spread-out system
without the strong
definitions given
by these are the
walls or the streets
or the monuments in that city.
This is not a
monumental city at all.
It's a sprawling, elegant
microtuned environment.
Next.
Here are two images of streets
in Florence being employed
for games and Marie de' Medici's
influence on the Cours la
Reine.
Next.
The Cours la Reine on the left,
a place for the wealthy to have
sex in a broad
sense of the word.
[LAUGHTER]
Next.
The great adventure
of perspective.
The capacity for
the middle class.
This is Caillebotte's
great painting.
It's in, I think, in the
Art Institute in Chicago.
The use of this
street with umbrellas.
Next.
The Place Royale, the
great aristocratic center.
The Place the Vosges
on the right, today.
Next.
The Rue Rambuteau.
Rambuteau's attempt
to build a street
without deficit financing help.
Next.
Haussmann and the
dark black being
the elements that he inserted
into the revised system.
Next.
Here, you get the details of a--
this the Boulevard Sebastopol.
That space is taken up at will.
This connector, it
doesn't matter that there
are houses underneath here.
The houses are just separated
away from the others
in order to make
a new imposition.
This is about as ruthless as--
and it's probably the
last time in history
that this is being able to be
done in a democratic society.
Next.
Napoleon didn't pay
much attention to Paris.
He wanted to make Paris
into a royal city.
And the East-West access through
the Champs-Élysées became his
primary focus, the Arc de
Triomphe being the connector--
not the connector--
being his great monument.
He also attempted to stretch
the Champs-Élysées eastward
to the Bastille.
It's an extraordinary
Haussmannian device.
This is the Avenue
Fourche, which
has the wealthiest real
estate in Europe on the sides.
This street is
about 450 feet wide.
That's about twice as wide
as Commonwealth Avenue.
And the Bois-- leading
to the Bois de Boulogne,
another one of
Haussmann's creations.
Here's the river.
Here's the intersection of the
Champs-Élysées into the Bois du
Boulogne and the Avenue Fourche.
Next.
The Académie Nationale de
Musique and the access to it,
the monument at the end of the
wide road, Avenue de l'Opera.
Next.
The interior of the opera by
Garnier, an extraordinary--
Walter Benjamin writes
about Paris and talks
about the invention of the
interior, the first time
that the interior
seen as significant.
And this study is done by the
students of Foucault, showing
the subdivision of
the French house
over time, introducing
what Benjamin calls
the adventure of the interior.
Next.
Here is the ultimate.
There's the Boulevard
Richard-Lenoir,
the ultimate expression of
destination and movement
and the interior connections.
Next.
The underground services
in the mid '90s,
the cross-section
of a Paris street.
And during one of the
exhibitions in Paris,
a trip through the sewage
system was a great pleasure.
Next.
The Banlieues, here is the
taking down of the dues,
tax houses on the--
where the octroi was
collected and the conditions
in the Banelieues.
Next.
In the street is war.
1848, the barricaded
streets in the center of--
on the east of--
on the east of Paris, here
are the barricade lines.
The use of this street is war.
Next.
1872, and the
two-month-long occupation
of the Western of the
Eastern part of Paris,
again, with the
use of barricades.
Barricades slow down
troops, and people
in the adjacent buildings
can fire down on the troops
when they slow down.
Next.
1968, and again the use
of this street in protest.
Next.
OK.